now it's no secret that a lot of social
media platforms tend to share features
from other platforms and then kind of
make them their own now Instagram is
obviously no stranger to this and they
just came out with something called the
Reds now I feel like this is a direct
competitor to Twitter and to be honest
with you I'm not mad about it Twitter
for me was always about the people it
was about my friends the people that I
was following random strangers that I
would be able to interact with
celebrities political figures and
everyone was kind of on this same kind
of plane like you were on Twitter to
share and interact with people so if you
guys haven't already be sure to follow
me at iJustine on threads I look forward
to seeing you guys over there now let's
take a closer look at the app now
already when I'm on the home feed it's
kind of populating a bunch of users who
I've either followed interacted with I'm
friends with and since I just signed up
I haven't really started following many
friends yet so far I'm only following
two people Laura DIY and Mark Zuckerberg
and I love that this ports over your
actual Instagram handle so you'll have
the same handle as your Instagram as you
will have on your threads so it's super
easy easy to find all of your friends so
the first thing that you'll see is the
home feed and this is where you'll see
all of your updates from your friends
next you have your search field which
for me this is populating a bunch of
people that have already been following
on Instagram and it also looks like
there's some suggested people to follow
as well now in here we have our activity
you can see my replies mentions nobody's
mentioned me yet that makes me sad we
gotta fix that and here's updates from
verified now when I click here this
takes you to your profile I've only
tweeted one single thing so far tweet it
oh my god do we say post I've only
posted one do I say I threaded what do
we call a thread post like oh I just
tweeted that okay I posted it oh my God
my second my second post this is
exciting so you can also copy a link to
these posts which kind of makes it seem
like it's also a mini blogging platform
it could also be a little rival to
medium as well you could like you can
comment repost or you can quote post I
mean if this isn't basically a Twitter
clone that I think that we've all been
waiting for yeah it is you can follow
invite your friend by WhatsApp SMS email
this is something that I really like
though in the settings you can take a
break so you can get a reminder to take
a break every 10 20 30 minutes or never
I think we might need to like add an
hour on there maybe oh somebody just
commented back said I just yarned I
think I I like that maybe I don't know
maybe that's weird I'm not sure you can
also post photos I haven't posted any
yet so let's test it out okay posting oh
can I edit because I meant to post
Southwest PA can we not edit post yet I
can't we can't edit posts what if I make
a mistake you can edit your profile you
can share and you can also go and check
your replies really quickly which I
actually really like that my friends is
threads that's Instagram's new potential
Twitter clone Twitter competition
Twitter killer if you guys want to you
can follow me at iJustine on threads and
let me know what kind of content you'd
like to see there and let me know how
you plan on using it I'll see you guys
on threads happy threading